it's true that two heads are better than
one
hey I thought I was going to start sorry
that mixture of mutual encouragement and
inspiration
that's how incredible things get made
Act one sweet success sweet success that
was mine I guess
two heads are sweeter than one James
Morrison and John C Wharton had one goal
to bring sugary sweets to the masses but
before their invention cotton candy was
a fancy food for fancy people because it
was just really hard to make Wharton a
candy maker passionate and eccentric and
Morrison open up yep that's right he was
a dentist combine forces to create the
first electric cotton candy machine
which used centrifugal force to spin
heated sugar
they brought their invention to the
World's Fair in 1904 changing the
carnival food game forevermore that's
what happens when you put two and two
together back to all about that paper
let's go way back in the day - somewhere
around mid 1800s right
e-even Scott and his younger brother
Clarence were very different people
urban was a real outdoorsman and the guy
loved hunting and fishing and putting
dead things on his wall you know stuff
like that
and Clarence was a Sunday school teacher
a bookish type but they were brought
together by one shared love paper they
opened a business together to sell all
kinds of products but it was their paper
towels that really cleaned up was that a
pun pun intended even from their
different backgrounds they both knew
that the world could be a little cleaner
speaking of which you could be a little
cleaner there's two sides to every story
ooh can I start the next one fine this
is my favorite act three radioactive
love Marie and Pierre Joey met in that
we studying together in a laboratory
they had serious chemistry ooh-la-la
Marie came from a difficult life in
Poland but became a pioneer in the
research of radioactivity P
who grew up home schooled in Paris
earned a math degree by the time he was
16 and studied magnetism before he began
working alongside Murray together they
discovered elements like polonium and
radium and experimented with their
practical applications like radiation
therapy as cancer treatment and in 1903
they were awarded the Nobel Prize in
Physics making Marie Curie the first
woman to ever win the award boom there's
no doubt we each have great ideas to
bring to the world but when we team up
with another mind we become so much more
and create truly incredible things twos
better you know I'm saying like doing me
really